alors ça c'est ce soir je fais une
petite chanson seven
je suis depuis trente ans michel dorion
pratiquer le métier de drague
je pense à ta prenne fait et donc mes
amis mon pti fourgous s'inscrivent donc
ils m'ont inscrit j'ai participé et j'ai
remporté le concours devenue miss
cabaret l'entrepôt 88
depuis ce temps leurs je roule ma bosse
[Musique]
véritable pilier de la communauté drague
il possède un cabaret dans le village
gai et dirige le spectacle d'illusion
présentée depuis 12 ans à fierté
montréal ce qui donne des contrats qui
fixent implique qu'ils peuvent souvent
pas de conseils aux gens qui l'entourent
et oissel viennent naturellement c'est
quelqu'un auquel beaucoup de gens se
réfèrent aussi le métier de drag queens
se professionnalise
depuis l'arrivée de la populaire
émission groupe aux railleries viols de
jeunes stars émergent comme l'acte et
chats neuf ans ce spectaculaire
moi j'aurais pas pu avoir la carrière de
l'acteur shia commencé à 9 à faire du
spectacle
ça prouve que les choses évoluent pour
michel dorion l'avenir s'annonce
prometteur
c'est un vrai métier je te promets
[Musique]
danse théâtre et drag queens and every
me charrier radio canada montréal